did you like working with stephen amell
um
yes i love steven he actually we have a
really good
well rapport friendship working
relationship and here
is what why i think
steven coming out of the gates this
was our conversation when we first met
steven hi okay
if you [ __ ] this up
i will [ __ ] kill you oh my god
don't [ __ ] this up for us all right
you're the lead
[ __ ] don't become an [ __ ] and if
you are
if you're gonna become an [ __ ] i'm
gonna let you let you know
you're being an [ __ ] yeah okay and he
he this is like right oh [ __ ] the pilot
i think
or he might have been a comic-con i
don't know but he
of course started cracking up and
i don't know it's like a he becomes he's
like kind of like a brother
in a way yeah i don't know but he has
respect for me
and he we can laugh at each other and i
roll my eyes at him and i've called him
out and he's called me out so
i love steven